hello you're watching mostly weekly and
I'm presumably andrew heaton happy Shark
Week congratulations to you sharks and
condolences to you seals you know who
isn't having a good Shark Week or human
week Jeff Sessions recently President
Trump criticized his Attorney General
saying he never should have given him
the job so why is Trump upset is it
because Jeff Sessions is a
megalomaniacal lying leprechaun no no
and tyranny Trump is upset because
sessions has recused himself from the
Russia investigation which might be the
only smart thing sessions has done
during his tenure so this week in
arbitrary challenges I will list as many
reasons as I can why Jeff Sessions is it
in under two minutes Jeff Sessions is
planning a pot crackdown which is not
the fun kind of pot crackdown which
involves pot crack and a hoedown Jeff
session has said that marijuana is only
slightly less awful than heroin to which
pot advocates say sessions is only
slightly less awful than Trump session
said he was heartbroken when President
Obama said marijuana is not as dangerous
as alcohol heartbroken marijuana not
being as dangerous as alcohol is a fact
true heartbreak is finding out that
snooty the world's oldest manatee died
one day after his birthday last week
RIT study in 1996 before Jeff Sessions
became the cuddly imp we all know in
love today he advocated the death
penalty for drug traffickers that were
convicted multiple times including for
dealing marijuana but hey it was the 90s
and he was just experimenting with cruel
and unusual punishments in Leh Jeff
Sessions asked Congress to allow him to
prosecute medical marijuana providers so
take that fat lazy cancer patients
recently Jeff Sessions expanded civil
asset forfeiture which allows police
officers to ignore state and local laws
and seize assets of anyone suspected of
a crime to make an analogy
this would be like if we were playing go
fish and you asked if I had any Queens
and then I said give me all the money in
your car because drugs sessions
reportedly believes that the sanctity of
life begins at conception and then
apparently in zip Burton Jeff Sessions
supports mandatory minimums for
nonviolent crimes so I vote we redefine
mandatory minimums to mean height
requirements for passing laws sessions
has come out repeatedly against gay
marriage confirming my new position of
redefining marriage is a union between
any two people who aren't Jeff Sessions
Jeff sessions has come out and
supportive torture
also he looks like a Keebler Elf that
planted drug events in the tree in large
jeff sessions failed to disclose that he
met with a russian ambassador and Nancy
Pelosi called for his resignation
the worst part now I have to agree with
Nancy Pelosi on something and worst of
all earlier this year Jeff sessions
offered to resign but that didn't go
through with it made it so remember Jeff
sessions is a pasty goblin who favors
tortures civil asset forfeiture and
locking people in cages for pot thanks
for watching
merry Shark Week all
[Applause]
[Music]